this is a video of DNA structure in 3d
I'll give you a moment to put on your VR
headset or realize you're in the wrong
place and find the 2d version of this
video there's a link in the video
description get that head set in place
and get ready to experience DNA in 3d
deoxyribonucleic acid or DNA is an
absolutely incredible molecule the
arrangement of its subunits codes nearly
all of the genetic information that
makes you well you most of your DNA is
located in the nucleus of the cell and
when it is time DNA makes every protein
and enzyme in your body and zaimes in
turn synthesize all of the biological
molecules you need to make on your own
carbohydrates hormones RNA everything
that's necessary for your tissues and
organs to function here we're looking at
a small piece of DNA rotating in 3d
space we'll come back to the structure
but for now let's focus on a single
repeating unit of DNA which is called a
nucleotide the nucleotide is made up of
a phosphate group which carries a
negative 2 charge on the oxygen atoms a
2 deoxyribose sugar named this way
because this is carbon 2 of the sugar
and it does not have an OHA
finally we have a nitrogenous base here
in DNA there are four common bases this
nucleotide is cited in mono phosphate if
we remove the phosphate group this
fragment is referred to as a nucleoside
and this one is called site adine to
remember the difference between
nucleotides and nucleosides I use this
mnemonic device a nucleotide is the
total fragment and the nucleoside with
an S contains only the sugar which
begins with s if we simplify this
structure even further we can focus in
on the base pair and see what makes the
four bases unique the bases are called
nitrogenous bases because they all
contain nitrogen atoms
their rings this nitrogenous base is the
molecule cytosine and is a pyramidal
ring perimeters are six-membered
heterocycle z-- with nitrogen atoms at
the 1 and 3 positions of the ring
cytosine has an amine group and a
carbonyl group this C double bond o
coming off of the perimeter ring two of
the nitrogenous bases are perimeters and
thymine is the other one
I mean differs from cytosine because it
contains two carbonyl groups an extra
ch3 and a different arrangement of the
double bonds within and around the ring
the other nitrogenous bases are purine
rings this one is adenine purines
contain a six membered ring fused to a
five membered ring with four nitrogen
atoms within the rings in this
arrangement adenine is characterized by
an amine group attached to the ring the
final base we need to know is guanine
the nh-2 group of adenine is replaced by
a carbonyl and there's an nh-2 group at
this position which was unsubstituted in
adenine because DNA is so long and made
up of so many nucleotides it is common
to abbreviate the base pairs as the
first letter of their name so the
perimeters are C and T and the purines
are a and G we had to look closely at
the structures of the bases because they
are key in holding the DNA double helix
together which we're looking at now the
orientation of the nitrogen oxygen and
hydrogen atoms allows hydrogen bonding
to occur between the strands and this is
why DNA exists as a double helix the
perimeter T pairs up with the purine a
making two hydrogen bonds between the
base pairs this one from the NH to
another nitrogen atom and this one from
the carbonyl outside the ring to the
hydrogen atom of this amine the other
pairing occurs between the pyramidal C
and the purine G
the hydrogen bonding is similar however
there's an extra amine carbonyl hydrogen
bond the three hydrogen bonds that hold
G and C together add extra stability to
the double helix and DNA that is rich in
G and C base pairs comes apart at the
hydrogen bonds or melts at a higher
temperature experimentally the sugars
and phosphate groups bond covalently to
make up the backbone of the DNA molecule
and we can see the alternating units
here phosphate sugar phosphate sugar the
two paired strands do not run in the
same direction they actually run anti
parallel or in opposite directions we
can see this by looking at the sugars
associated with a single base pair
notice how the oxygen atom points upward
here but points downward on this side
each terminus of the DNA strand can be
labeled as either 3 prime or 5 prime and
this depends on the direction that the
sugar is facing the numbering of the
sugar carbon atoms begins where the
sugar attaches to the nitrogenous base
now we can count the carbon atoms in the
order that they are connected 1 2 3 4 5
since this terminal o H group is on the
fifth carbon of the sugar this is a 5
prime end let's wind around the DNA
strand so that we can look at the other
end of that same strand
notice the O H group here is on the 1 2
3 third carbon atom this is the 3 prime
end of that same strand now let's
retrace our steps zooming back up to
that 5 prime end that we first looked at
and now we're going to move over to its
complementary strand that it's hydrogen
bonded to the Frio h group here
is that the one two three third carbon
atom so this is another three prime end
in order to make new cells to grow or
replace dead cells the entire strand of
DNA needs to be copied to do this the
double helix is unzip by enzymes and an
exact copy of each strand of DNA is made
before the cell divides up with perfect
copies of the genetic material in each
cell what we're looking at now is DNA
being unzipped by an enzyme called a
helicase
notice how the unwound strand of DNA is
held apart from its complementary strand
by being buried into the interior of the
enzyme this structure was actually not
captured using protein crystallography
it was done using a technique called
cryo-electron microscopy and the
pioneers of this technique won the Nobel
Prize for cryo a.m. in 2017 if you
unwound all of the DNA in your cell and
lined it up end to end it would be about
two meters long considering the fact
that each nucleotide is only about 60
nanometers much smaller than even the
wavelength of light these are extremely
long chains of nucleotides in order to
package the DNA strands to fit into the
nucleus of your cells proteins called
histones whine the DNA around themselves
in what is called a nucleosome
scientists have been able to capture
crystal structures of parts of these
nucleus home complexes and that's what
we're looking at right now notice the
way the DNA becomes wrapped around these
proteins in such an orderly fashion
so amazing I truly hope you enjoyed
stepping inside of DNA if you want to
take more macro molecular journeys with
me please like this video and subscribe
to my channel